you know when I think about when I used
to upgrade and you know the in the days
of yesteryear right
I didn't ask asked myself if I could
really afford it I guess maybe I asked
myself if I could afford the debt
payment or if I could have if I could
afford maybe that in you know in that
instant if I had the cash on me but it's
funny man like when I look at my past
decisions being in debt with a mortgage
being in debt with a car being in debt
with credit cards being in debt with
student loans I couldn't afford anything
no but somehow you were broke even
though ostensibly you weren't yeah and
and you know I could find ways to
justify buying different things but
ultimately I mean now I look at my life
if I am in debt and I want to buy
something that I'd necessarily don't
need if I'm in debt I can't I'm broke I
can't afford it so I could you know just
just don't think of the monetary costs
either think about the space they have
to take up think about the care that you
have to have for those clothes
the psychological weight of holding on
to them even though you don't like them
yeah and so there there are all kinds of
additional costs that are embedded in
holding on to items also bringing new
items in and we have to we have to keep
in mind all of those costs
you